[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the game is fun the game is a battle if
it's not fun why bother if it's not a
battle where's the fun it's a test that
you pass or a quest that you fail or
race against time fun and battle always
lock together but the game is also
something else
it's a journey a passport to new worlds
maybe even an odyssey a look a feel an
exploration close your focus and open
your mind yes the journey requires the
right ticket and that ticket is Nintendo
switch but in the end it's not just
where you can take your game it's where
your game can take you so let's go
[Music]
[Music]
story goes that when the world was young
everyone in our rest lived on the world
tree together with our divine father the
architect
[Music]
they called that paradise Elysium
[Music]
Nora
blade
as the driver of the aegis
can you take me to easy
[Music]
I'm in let's go to Elysium I'll take you
there myself
Kyra dear
cover me
[Music]
we'll show you will show you what me and
Pyrrha made
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
now that you have come this far there
can be no turning
[Music]
and that sword shall be
I'm guessing your
is Elysium
[Music]
what's the matter
the ages
I won't use that power and I know that
you use it either
if you know
you will have to show it not with words
but with your own strength
everyone let go
sometimes you need a hero a
sword-swinging fire wielding stone-cold
hero with an insatiable appetite
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
nothing hi everyone I'm Shinya takahashi
from Nintendo I hope you've been
enjoying the journey with Nintendo
switch so far when I found out that
Nintendo switch is being accepted by
video game fans from all over the world
as a home console that could be taken
with you anywhere I felt so relieved
take switch outside come together and
share the experience this idea was how
we hoped people would play with Nintendo
switch but people are coming up with
many creative ways to play in all kinds
of places in many more ways than we
expected this summer Nintendo and its
third-party partners will release many
multiplayer games that can be played
anytime anywhere and with anyone we hope
there will be many heated competitions
that will be ignited by Nintendo switch
now we'll continue our look at even more
new game worlds for Nintendo switch but
before we do there is one announcement
we'd like to share from our very special
friend please take a look when you draw
hi everyone I'm Tanaka's Ishihara from
the Pokemon company just the other day
we announced that pokken tournament
deluxe is coming to Nintendo switch this
is the latest version of the premiere
pokemon fighting game two people can
dive right into battle using two joy
Khan controllers so you can experience
heated Pokemon battles with just one
Nintendo switch console there are some
fresh additions including new Pokemon
and this deluxe version of the game will
be on display at e3 for attendees to
play I have one more announcement Game
Freak has begun developing a core RPG
Pokemon title on Nintendo switch it may
not release for more than a year but we
hope you'll look forward to it all the
same in the meantime let's enjoy this
year's e3
Jonathan you should hurt us on thank you
very much we heard that the Pokemon
series is being developed for Nintendo
switch what kind of Pokemon game will we
be able to play on Nintendo switch I'm
looking forward to it myself at this
year's e3 we're mostly showing games
that will be released in 2017 but please
know that here at Nintendo we're working
on many forms of entertainment that can
only be made possible on Nintendo switch
we hope you look forward to them as well
now let's continue on with the journey
with Nintendo switch
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your attack mother's in danger
[Music]
you two must keep going no I'm coming
with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am Martha the prince of all taya we've
come here to save you remember that you
can rely on your friends we are with you
get it together you two if you can't do
this who can
you fought your way this far there's
nothing you two can't do no matter the
danger we can overcome it if we're
working together all right
let's know that working together we can
finish this
[Applause]
you
[Music]
hi there
I'm the Legend of Zelda series producer
Eiji Aonuma you may have already heard
about it during bethesda showcase that
was held a few days ago it was announced
that select Zelda items will appear in
the Nintendo switch version of Skyrim
I'm really looking forward to exploring
Skyrim with the master sword in hand oh
when did this Master Sword get in my
hand next up we'll take a look at the
DLC packs for The Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild let us take you on a new
Hyrule adventure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
what did you think I actually have one
more announcement that I'd like to share
the four champions that appeared in the
Legend of Zelda breadth of the wild will
be available as amiibo the zora champion
MIFA the Goron champion diruk the rito
champion Ravalli and the Gerudo champion
herb osa you'll be able to use these
four amiibo in the Legend of Zelda
breadth of the wild of course you'll be
able to use these in the DLC packs that
you just saw so please look forward to
them this changes the game
travel the world bring people together
play anywhere with anyone if video
gaming is a journey then anywhere has to
include a stop right here in LA during
e3 this is Magic week where booths buzz
and channels glow where the game worlds
you've heard about suddenly spring into
life and this summer a new kind of
heated competition ignites right on
Nintendo switch it kicks off later today
with the splatoon 2 world inkling
Invitational which brings teams from the
Americas Europe Australia New Zealand
and Japan to see whose colorful skills
are the best
tomorrow the pokken invitational will be
held you might recognize some of our
eight competitors who will be duking it
out in heated battles later on Wednesday
will see eight players throw punches and
the fun and competitive game arms which
launches later this week four of our
players will be pros and the other four
will be III attendees who rise to the
top by battling on the show floor if
you're going to e3
we hope you'll accept the challenge and
no matter where you are be sure to catch
up with Nintendo treehouse live at e3
for all the details and news about
Nintendo switch and Nintendo 3ds
but now there are a few more worlds left
to visit on our journey before we land
in the booth let's go
[Music]
Ubisoft is proud to announce in new
Rabbids game my o+ rabbit's kingdom
battle and it will be developed
exclusively for the Nintendo switch the
rabbits crazy personalities and
unpredictable behavior will shine as
they arrive in a reimagined and twisted
Mushroom Kingdom they would surprise you
in this tactical adventure filled with
combat and exploration my o
ernie's friends would join them in an
epic quest to put the kingdom back in
order we can't wait for you to play the
game on August 29
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on behalf of everyone here at psyonix
we're extremely excited to announce that
Rockley is indeed coming the Nintendo
switch we know that both the rocket
league and switch communities have
wanted it and now we're going to release
it complete with cross network support
that lets you play against opponents on
other platforms the switch version will
have all the features and modes we've
released thus far plus exclusives like
local wireless multiplayer Mario and
Luigi hats for customizing your car and
new exclusive cards we'll talk about
later this year look for rocket League a
Nintendo switch this holiday
come on
[Music]
here we go
it's time to raise
[Music]
jump with me girl coins with me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
superstar
[Music]
get right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you